[Music]
Hollywood has always been political
always been on the left but in the last
year and a half or so things have spun
completely out of control a political
movement has become a revolution like
all revolutions it has become it is
eating itself even the biggest Hollywood
stars are no longer safe from the mobs
they created for example actress
Scarlett Johansson was supposed to play
a transgendered person upcoming film but
had to quit the role after left-wing
activists attacked her for not giving
that role to someone who was actually
transgendered Daniela Greenbaum is a
writer and until a few days ago she
worked at Business Insider she wrote a
piece defending Scarlett Johansson for
taking the role she said she's an actor
she should be allowed to act but
Business Insider under pressure from
activist deleted the piece and she
resigned in protest Daniela Greenbaum
joins us tonight Daniel it's kind of an
amazing story give us the book outlines
who your piece basically I hope I'm not
miss characterizing it said this is an
actress who is an actor who was paid to
portray other people that's what she
seeks to do here there's nothing wrong
with that is that was that your argument
basically yes I thought that I wrote
something totally benign and I basically
said actors are paid to represent people
who aren't themselves that's what she's
been hired to do and I don't understand
the outrage frankly well I mean it's
sort of an unimpeachable point
how did Business Insider Nicolas Carlson
I think was your editor over there how
did he respond what did he say to you
what was wrong with that piece well Nick
is the editor in chief over there and
about I don't know maybe three four or
five hours after the piece went up on a
Friday morning I got on a call with him
and some of the other senior staff there
and they informed me that many of my
colleagues had written them letters very
upset at the point I had made and how I
had made it and ultimately they decided
to take the piece down what were they
upset about I mean do they have a case
against your point well frankly I don't
really understand their point but I
think most of it was rooted in that I
did not give serious consideration to
the point being made by the other side
that may be because transgender people
face discrimination in other walks of
life the
film-industry somehow owes it to them to
find them these jobs or that
quote-unquote that their narratives are
being stolen and my argument was acting
is about stealing narratives right we
don't cast people gonna present
themselves and so this should not be
treated any differently so do they ever
fully flesh out their point of view or
was it just the kind of sense that you'd
violated some rule that decent people
don't violate you said something naughty
therefore like we're punishing you well
I was forwarded some of the letters that
my colleagues had written I guess the
ones that had said you know we're fine
with Daniela seeing that we wrote this
and again they made the argument that
there are limited roles for transgender
people and you know there's limited
roles rather that portray transgender
people on that therefore they should
somehow have first dibs and my argument
was yes well I just I'm just worried
we're almost out of time and I just
since you practice journalism yes I mean
what does it do to journalism I mean our
audience can assess but I think you're
making a totally moderate reasonable
point you don't seem crazy at all I
think most people would agree if you
can't say something that obvious and
sensible like can you practice
journalism in an environment like that
well the thing is that I always thought
I was inoculated against this kind of
silencing because I do identify as
moderate I mean I'm right-of-center but
I'm pretty moderate and so I was naive
to think that I was sort of immune from
this kind of attack but the reality is
that each victory that this mob claims
just strengthens them and reminds them
of their own strength and so I don't
think anyone is safe from this kind of
attack that's exactly right that's a
really smart point Godspeed I hope you
find employment somewhere much better
than Business Insider Thank You Daniela